[Música]
seguimos en directo américa ahora con la
revista de prensa de la mano de rosa
pérez además de buenos días para usted
rosa y vamos a empezar con la
informaciones de última hora de su
sección el periódico ruso nóvaya gazeta
cesa sus operaciones buenos dias angela
así es esto lo acabamos de aprender hace
apenas una hora no y es que este medio
de comunicación que ha sido uno de los
que se ha intentado mantener más crítico
contra el kremlin en este contexto no de
la invasión rusa de ucrania acaba de
anunciar su cese total de las
operaciones al menos temporalmente en su
página web leemos el siguiente
comunicado recibimos otra advertencia
del roscón asador recordemos el
organismo de moscú que regula las
telecomunicaciones después de esto
suspendemos las publicaciones de nuestro
periódico en nuestra página web en redes
sociales y en papel hasta el final de la
operación especial en territorio
ucraniano y pone operación especial en
territorio ucraniano entre comillas no
sinceramente los editores de nóvaya
gazeta
pero antes de este anuncio este medio
ruso publicaba las últimas novedades del
caso de la ex productora del canal uno
de rusia exactamente este medio ha
venido siguiendo muy de cerca todo este
caso no recordemos que marina oceánico
va es la productora del canal 1 de
noticias como comentabas que el 14 de
marzo protestó de forma digamos
espontánea en directo en medio de los
informativos de la noche de este canal
de televisión al ruso uno de los más
importantes contra la guerra rusa en
ucrania y acabamos como decías de
conocer cuáles son las últimas novedades
de la judía de judicialización de este
caso y nos cuenta nos contaba nóvaya
gazeta que un tribunal de moscú descarta
abrir la judicialización por la vía
penal porque no encuentra bases para
perseguir a oceánico va en base a este
artículo que se aprobó pues a raíz de
esta invasión rusa que persigue las
difamaciones contra las fuerzas armadas
rusas pero que sí que se mantiene el
caso por la vía administrativa
de hecho se celebrará la audiencia el 14
de abril y le puede caer aus yannick o
va una multa de entre 300 a 500 mil
rublos pero recordemos que el día
después de esta protesta ya fue
sancionada con una multa de 300 mil
rubros lo que equivale a unos 300
dólares pero no por la protesta en
directo sino por este vídeo que ella
publicó también en redes sociales
llamando a una protesta masiva de los
rusos contra la guerra bueno y en la
misma tónica a la entrevista de medios
rusos independientes a volodymyr
selenski que ese objeto de censura
exactamente y es que precisamente cuatro
periodistas críticos con el kremlin
cuatro periodistas rusos de los medios
medusa de esta televisión que se traduce
como rain también que fue sancionada
bloqueada en rusia del kommersant y
también un periodista independiente que
preguntaba también en nombre del nóvaya
gazeta e hicieron una entrevista de 90
minutos por su al presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski sin embargo los dos
medios rusos participando de esta
entrevista el comer y en nóvaya gazeta
decidieron no publicarla porque
recibieron una advertencia pues poco
después de ser anunciada esta entrevista
por parte del organismo del regulador de
las comunicaciones ruso en que les
advertía que incluso los periodistas que
habían participado de esta entrevista
podrían ser perseguidos no por la
justicia rusa sin embargo si la
publicaron medusa por ejemplo y en esta
entrevista encontramos que es el lens
que comenta un poco distintos temas
desde el bloque hago de mariupol explica
que en las calles de esta ciudad
asediada por las fuerzas rusas pues hay
cadáveres de militares rusos de civiles
ucranianos también acusa al kremlin de
llevarse a dos mil niños ucranianos a
paradero desconocido y pido pide a estos
medios que tomen la responsabilidad de
luchar contra la desinformación y
cambiar la sociedad rusa algo pues un
poco arriesgado judicialmente no angela
y por último comentó de lentes que
también que la censura de esta
entrevista es trágica y en el moscú time
se aumentaron los problemas de salud
mental en rusia desde que comenzó la
invasión
ucrania o esta operación especial eso es
lo que encontramos en este artículo que
asegura que desde que empezó esta
invasión en rusia se han cuadriplicado
la venta de fármacos contra la ansiedad
y contra la depresión también explica
que personas que ya padecían problemas
de salud mental están teniendo problemas
para encontrar los fármacos que precisan
y que cuando los encuentran sobre todo
si se trata de fármacos importados pues
es a un alto precio también da el
testigo de personas que están padeciendo
las consecuencias de la incertidumbre
económica pues en la que se encuentra a
su país ahora mismo también la
frustración ante que pues rusia haya
iniciado esta invasión brutal de ucrania
y sin embargo el kremlin atribuye a esta
escasez a una compra masiva no en base a
este pánico y asegura que con la
producción rusa se va a poder suplir
pues a las faltas de fármacos importados
y otra noticia que golpea los medios
internacionales la deutsche welle fue
calificada como agente extranjero en
rusia exactamente esto también es una
noticia de esta mañana
recordemos que agente extranjero
significa este no es la noticia que está
que estábamos mencionando la siguiente
agente extranjero es lo que el kremlin
califica como una organización que es
financiada principalmente pues por
fondos extranjeros y así ha sido
calificada la deutsche welle hoy mismo
después de que esta televisión pública
de información internacional de alemania
fuera bloqueada ya en rusia a principios
de marzo y precisamente recuperamos este
artículo que escribió la propia deutsche
welle explicando qué significa que una
organización no sea calificada de
agentes extranjeros y pues entre otras
cosas cada una de las referencias que
sea esta organización debe ir acompañada
por un asterisco así lo encontramos con
distintas organizaciones en los medios
rusos no un astérix tico y abajo de la
publicación pone la organización
considerada agente extranjero por el
kremlin y también implica para esta
misma organización pues pasar muchos
controles sobre sus operaciones y
actividades con el kremlin así también
como una teague matización y es una
forma también por parte de desalentar a
los ciudadanos oa otras organizaciones a
que se relacionen con las que han sido
categorizadas como agentes extranjeros
pues cosa muy preocupante y de todas
maneras el agradecimiento a ustedes por
ese reporte tan completo y vamos a pasar
ahora a nuestro invitado del día